first and foremost you have to realize  in a real way in a non [ __ ] way that  you work for them if you do not do that  you've lost number two you have to  realize that there is no blanket rules  you have to micromanage 330 people so  wants ambitions and needs on an everyday  basis what else is it work-life balance  is it like are they a huge you know  Chelsea fan and something about me right  the other thing is you have to build  infrastructure last Friday I announced a  new role that I Dennis was the most  senior role in a company besides me with  Claud summer who's now my partner  basically in the company she's the chief  part boss she will help me scale the  mapping of one to one scale to build  great culture is not only through words  that are written on the wall but in your  actions you Eponine every one of those  people who understand